- I could watch game tape or.... '07 Pats
highlights.
- [Belichick:] Do your job.
- [Voice:] The autumn wind...
- Ah! Raiders have a mascot?
I can't get anything to work.
AHHH!
IT'S SO CREEPY UP CLOSE!
- Sever him, Raider Rusher.
- This is just disgusting fan service.
AHHHHH. ANYTHING BUT THE $40 MILLION DOLLARS!!
- [cheering]
- All I have to do is sit in this hot seat and split my focus equally?
This is too easy.
Or I could give Tyler Allgeier all
the looks.
- [Bijan:] Coach! Coach!
- Our scary mascot is coming for you.
- [Bowles:] They say mascots come alive
and take out coaches on the hot seat.
- That's just a myth like the boogeyman
or the divisional round.
Plus, we don't even have a mascot.
- Every team has a mascot.
- At ease, Major Tuddy.
Commander outranks Major.
And as a commanding officer,
I said stand down!
AHHH! AHHH!
- I have nothing to fear
but Captain Fear himself.
AH!
His unibrow matches his mustache.
- LOOK OUT, IT'S STALEY!
- Aw thank you.
I do think we're a bit of a scary team.
- Not you. Staley Da Bear.
- Sorry, I don't know your confusing lore.
- Help! He looks sleepy, but he's not!
[Eberflus:] AH!
- Where's the deadbolt?
- [Boltman:] The only deadbolt...
IS YOU.
- You're not even team-approved!
- AH! Hey, with your size maybe I could start you at tight end-
- They wanted me to sit on that hot seat.
But I have more security than anyone.
- Eventually, we will have to take him out.
My big headed friend.
- [Creepy Voice:] OHHH CANADDAAAAA....
- Yeah? Coach Tomlin?
I was told you wanted me down from the booth.
Wait, that magnificent chin.
That beautiful, American-made I-beam.
Oh, God. It's Steely MC-